Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P, here is a caller who is worried about
me, and I always appreciate concern from people
in the audience.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, it's James.
I was watching some of your earlier videos
from earlier, but this is from a couple of
years ago.
One in particular stands out.
I believe it was called CALLER Needs help
with Jewish Person.
And you seem like you're in a much better
place.
You are in much higher spirits of the times.
Really joyful the venue you have recently.
How are you?
All right.
There's something happened.
You seem kind of down in the dumps recently.
Well.
Speaker 1: The concern, nothing in particular
has happened.
Certainly the state of affairs in the United
States is quite sad.
That is true.
So I think it would be logical as someone
who is steeped in how things are going to
be sort of concerned.
But at the same time, the video that the caller
is referring to, I believe happened while
Trump was president, which was certainly a
dark time in American history.
So, no, I appreciate the concern.
Nothing in particular is wrong.
I mean, listen, let's be honest.
Chasing around a baby is exhausting.
So if anything could be blamed for tiredness
or whatever, certainly it would be it would
be that.
But no, everything is fine.
Thanks for asking.
On the bonus show today, folks.
We have a fantastic bonus show today.
I just got back from a wedding in California.
I am going to talk about elements that took
place on the flight, some unfortunate confrontations
that took place.
Not good.
I'm going to talk about running into some
really nice folks who watched the show while
I was in the Bay Area of California, met some
great people just by chance.
There was no event or anything.
Just ran into some great people.
I am going to talk about what else am I going
to talk about?
I have stories.
I have stories from California.
We are also going to talk about an investigation
into the cause of the implosion of that Titanic
submersible.
We're going to discuss that.
And also, Japan has a plan to boost birth
rates.
We've talked about the plan before.
Is it a viable plan?
We're starting to gather data.
One city has reason to hope that this is a
good plan for Japan to raise birth rates,
where birth rates are getting dangerously
low.
From a political standpoint, all of those
stories and more will be in none other than
today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money.
Yeah.
Speaker 3: Everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: And of course, after being back
for one day, I will be off for the next three
weeks.
No, I'm kidding.
We're back.
We're back for a while before before the next
break.
It's not even really a break anymore, you
know.
By the way, let's just talk a little bit about
the guest hosts.
Every time we have guest hosts, I get e-mails.
All right.
I'm going to tell everybody right now.
I know that not everybody likes the guest
hosts.
I know it because every guest host we have
no matter what.
We get e-mails from people saying I couldn't
bear to watch it.
Some people liked Luke, but they didn't like
Pat.
Some people like Pat, but they didn't like
Luke.
Some people didn't like either.
Some people said both were fine, but it wasn't
that good.
So I'm just going to put it out there.
We used to have no shows when I would be away.
It wasn't really.
Robust.
One of the things I've wanted to do is have
a more robust show that can continue when
I'm gone.
We now have multiple people who can do the
producer role.
We have a rotating cast of guest hosts.
I understand and I'm flattered that when I'm
gone.
Some people say, David, I'd rather have you
here.
And that makes sense because you're watching
this show or listening to this show rather
than some other show.
So I get that and I love that and I'm flattered
by it.
But you don't have to email me that you don't
like the guest hosts or all of the guest hosts,
because I know that not everybody likes them.
Viewership goes down when we have a guest
host.
But my opinion is and people in the audience
seem to agree it's better to have a guest
host rather than no show or a repeat show,
because if it's part of your routine to listen
to a podcast on the way to work, on the way
to the gym, whatever, and you don't necessarily
want to find something else, we have something
there, and I think viewership is usually down
about 30% when we have guest host, which isn't
really that bad, I have to tell you.
All right.
So you you can always email for any reason,
but if you're just emailing in to say, hey,
I didn't like the guest hosts, we know we
see that in the data and we're going to continue
working to have a great rotating slate of
hosts that will hold down the fort until I
get back.
I'll write more about my trip on the bonus
show.
We'll be back tomorrow.
We have a very strong week of programing.